someone's gonna get hurt I mean we don't
have any options oh my god that's
settled we towards us now immediately
move to a safe area Ginga you know that
people have done giant Jenga in the past
but no one's done giant Jenga using
cinder blocks people could break bones
if this stack falls on you the wrong way
so try to be safe work with your partner
only two people in the circle at a time
other than that let's see how high we
can take this thing because I'm excited
I'm super excited this is gonna be
awesome
we've got three teams it's gonna be me
and Nick Clint and Ren Carmichael and
Christian each team is gonna go once in
order and we're just gonna repeat that
order
tell the stack Falls don't try this at
home someone's gonna get hurt no it's
not true I realize in building this
Jenga tower it could be the last time I
ever have a chance to tell you guys
about today's sponsor Squarespace you've
heard me talk all about Squarespace up
and down the four frames of this video
on so many other videos in the past
you've heard me talk about how they have
beautiful award-winning designer
templates that make building a website a
breeze heard me talk about their 24/7
customer service heck you've even heard
me talk about their marketing tools
marketing or tell people that you're
releasing a new product or doing an
event it's super easy with Squarespace
heck you've even probably heard me say
how Squarespace has a unique domain
experience and how you can transfer a
domain from anywhere to Squarespace in
just a couple of clicks Squarespace has
an all-in-one platform it means that
guys like me you don't know anything
about building a website are able to
make one for the business do you see the
corridor digital comm website have you
seen it lately Gabe and I just updated
it I gotta say looks awesome generally
pretty good for somebody that doesn't
know anything about Web Design you know
how
Squarespace so even though this might be
the last time I ever get to tell you
guys about Squarespace don't let this be
the last time you take advantage of
their services you get 10% off your
first purchase just go to
squarespace.com slash corridor crew just
think of it this way we're looking out
for you all right so each team pick a
Chinchin participant attention none
attention - all right we go last that's
what I wanted we go first all right wait
what take it down if you see that just
like you're dry yourself off after a
shower and just after a shower like nice
nice and dry
[Music]
you got this okay good
not even care you got it
nope not even touching it danger level
is going up you're trying to choose a
block
from here middle go middle I'm gonna go
metal this is probably like six foot ten
right now the more we do this it's
getting more and more dangerous
that's if we have to bust out a ladder
and you have to jump down a ladder can
avoid the tower if it's going down why
don't we just bring over a table and
stand on the table those are bad ideas
one more level though what we're gonna
need to play we're definitely will
definitely need a - I think we should go
down below or share on God so we need to
look at we need to try to balance it out
and bring some weight back to the other
side the only way to do that is to
remove weight from the side that has the
pressure which is the hardest side to
remove it from and if we take that one
out it's gonna fall over there somewhere
I got to say what people say run they're
gonna go yes the trees in G word yeah
it's the precip do either the pre safety
word is fall this is starting to get
sketch this is the most dangerous point
though when you when you pull a brick
when you pull a reckon to let your guard
down that's the most dangerous point how
much does a single brick way you figure
that way ten pounds
okay which way is it meaning any side
underneath particular sides
yeah
[Music]
release some of the weight those we've
almost doubled the height so we
shouldn't be talking to the players in
the field right now because we should
treat it like a lifetime hey Carmichael
what'd you have for breakfast
stop it Mike this is sketchy this is
like serious sketches yeah careful
[Music]
for anything
future
this is the way
[Music]
can you try pushing too long as you cool
out
ready fairly quick to go up just walk
away
[Music]
code
okay here comes the place yeah yeah a
little bit more oh snap there it is oh
my god
safety word is would it literally run if
anyone yells it stop what you're doing
stop filming just immediately move to a
safe area
[Music]
so whatever we need whatever we put on
needs to be put on the backside I feel
I'm gonna audition this brick right here
nope okay that one's not budget what
about bottom middle food that's not
gonna budge it
no yeah basically the ball roe is glued
to the dirt
[Music]
directly walk away read this one
okay read read and be very careful it's
doable Ren but you gonna be very careful
I'm yeah plant you could go towards you
I'm looking right at it
yeah okay that Ren support the bow
Slean you're backing up everything yeah
[Music]
and your turn to Jake what are we gonna
do I'm serious dude this is serious oh
man high stakes Jacobs and some high
stakes Jacob
my father died in the Jenga accident now
I must have engine moving the line back
okay this tower is falling towards the
safety line so we're moving the safety
line back all right let's take our best
shot to us now
we don't mean we don't have many options
yeah
no no no it's not fun it's not fun
[Music]
son is budget
crossing its yeah doing this so it's
gonna want to fall right there yeah
I don't think it's gonna fall I think
you're good
don't say that keep an eye on we're
getting down a single brick territory
now single bricks two layers deep Jake's
been working on that brick for about 30
minutes
yeah well I was coming free hold on I'm
afraid
yes
[Music]
be free yeah hands-free
it's one of those three ladder makes it
a few times dangerous when you go tour
coming
[Music]
yeah that's Carmichael you're right Enzo
I hope you guys get it I'm rooting for
you and my hands here little I'll knock
it forward it's not very even up here
though
it's gonna come down this
origen you got this call
just going yeah if we can move this one
that will bounce that little this was
moving you're going
[Music]
okay this is gonna be it
easy easy easy
you got it you got it
ladder ladder ladder letter I got this I
got this night now once you place it
hold it steady
okay put it to the center oh my god
that's a shuttle coming towards us now
it's gonna fall a note in the center
putting a center are you kidding me
[Music]
is it really my reach is over eight feet
tall right now and this is taller than
that handsome to even go up to this
thing well the problem is that as we
stack it higher the center of gravity
gets smaller and smaller so meaning that
its potential to fall in any direction
gets greater just stressing me out I've
never been the stressed out of the game
because I can't adjust it from here it
might go you given it almost went its
hook what happens when you max out Jen
Tommy have no mood yeah let's go down
with a fight so I can't even talk I'm
like nervous standing here if you move
anything on that side any if you if you
reduce anything on that side it's gonna
fall that way that one is gonna make it
fall - OH
[Music]
before they've done
you ready
[Music]
where's it going you're the you're in
the safest spot
nice and slow no I'll try
Jake's trying to go middle part of its
gonna go that way and the top is gonna
talk away this
[Music]
Jake you got this you got this boy
what just nice and
that is what I'm talking about how did
we how did we not lose hey before we go
down what's the name of the Tom Cruise
movie that he's a sort agent students
Jerry Maguire Jerry Maguire show me the
money so we're back in this position
again I don't know how I got all the way
back around we took it we got out a good
way though here we go there's like no
this one has two points two points of
contact yeah so I don't think I need to
get the ladder to confirm just checking
to see if this one's loose enough this
one's got one point of contact the press
f2 two three
I think that's the best odds it's also
very high up and it doesn't go against
what's going up on the top to my heart's
really racing Dean so much to have you
here this one yet
[Music]
[Applause]
power up with it
[Laughter]
[Music]
we have our chance okay now I got we got
we got a breeze we gotta hold this for a
moment really there's a breeze do it
wait stop stop not fall
[Music]
oh my god survived so cool satisfying it
was so controlled yeah guys I'd like to
just thank everyone for doing such a
good job obeying safety protocols yes
feel like that is the debt that was the
key to no one getting hurt here and we
still I mean three two ones they say
next time we chop an arrow in half with
a sword while it's sitting on a
workbench